-Qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'une femme, pour vous ?
-Louis, 15 ans et demi, en 3e
au lycée Champollion, à Grenoble.
-Ca peut être la compagne
de l'homme dans la vie.
-Pourquoi "ça peut être" ?
Ca pourrait ne pas l'être ?
Ce serait quoi, alors ?
-C'est un être humain,
..au même titre que l'homme,
si elle ne se marie pas.
-Pourquoi si elle se marie ?
-Si elle se marie,
dans les conditions actuelles,
..elle ne peut pas être l'égale
de l'homme dans le mariage.
-Pourquoi ?
-Les structures sociales
sont faites de telles façons..
..que la femme ne peut pas
être l'égal de l'homme.
-Elle est quoi, alors,
à ce moment-là...
Elle est une machine
à faire des enfants ?
-Pas tout à fait,
mais elle est presque..
..la servante de l'homme.
-Vous êtes d'accord avec ça ?
-Non, pas du tout.
-Caroline à 15 ans et demi,
comme Louis.
Depuis ses 15 ans,
comme toutes les jeunes filles,
..Caroline peut se marier.
-Vous êtes prête à vous marier ?
-Maintenant, pas du tout.
Me marier maintenant... ?
Pas du tout. Loin de là.
-Pourquoi ?
-Parce que...
Je ne suis pas encore
assez stable.
De toute façon,
il faudrait que j'ai un fiancé,
..ou un ami.
Mais c'est ridicule de commencer
sa vie à 15 ans.
-Est-ce que vous redoutez
de vous marier maintenant ?
-Oui. Craindre de ne pas
pouvoir vivre pendant 40 ans..
..avec le même homme..
..sans savoir vraiment
que je l'aime..
..et que je pourrais
vivre avec lui.
-Marie-France, vendeuse
dans un petit magasin de tissu.
15 ans, juste.
-C'est quoi un mari, pour vous ?
-Quelqu'un qui restera
toujours auprès de moi,
..qui, quand même...
Faire marcher le ménage, non,
car c'est le rôle de la femme,
..mais qui tiendra quand même
une grande partie dans ma vie.
-Quel est son rôle, alors ?
-Il doit faire son travail.
Dès qu'il a fini ceci,
..il doit rentrer à la maison,
et ne plus rien faire.
Ce n'est pas son rôle
de s'occuper du ménage..
..ou des enfants.
Il doit trouver le ménage fait,
..le repas tout prêt,
..trouver un foyer calme
en rentrant.
-Pour vous,
le mariage est-ce une façon..
..de devenir une femme,
c'est-à-dire libre,
..ou est-ce une prison ?
-C'est une façon
de devenir plus libre,
..bien que je le suis déjà
beaucoup.
Je ne sais pas...
Je me mets dans l'idée que
je serais encore plus libre.
C'est peut-être bête, mais...
-Estimez-vous que
c'est nécessaire d'avoir..
..des expériences sexuelles
avant le mariage ?
-Pas pour une femme.
-Pourquoi ?
-Parce que j'ai envie
de rester pure pour mon mari.
-Et les garçons,
c'est différent de vous ?
Il ne sera pas pur, lui.
-Ce ne fait rien. Un garçon
a quand même besoin d'avoir..
..des liaisons.
C'est tout à fait naturel.
[Musique valse.]
-Comment vous voyez-vous
dans 15 ans ?
-Mariée...
Avec des enfants.
-Pourquoi avez-vous
poussé un soupir ?
-Parce qu'on aimerait toujours
rester à un âge, vers les 18 ans.
On n'aimerait plus bouger.
Mais pas avoir 30 ans.
C'est dur de vieillir.
-Vieillir, c'est terrible ?
-Oui.
-Pourquoi ?
-Je ne sais pas. J'aimerais
toujours rester jeune, m'amuser...
C'est affreux.
Je voudrais toujours avoir
18 ans, mais ne plus vieillir.
Dès qu'on a atteint
la trentaine,
..même en atteignant 19 ans,
..on se dit :
"c'est fini, on vieilli."
-Elle, s'appelle Odile.
Son père à une ferme
de 2 ha à 50 km de Grenoble.
Il faut l'imaginer, aller et venir
dans la ferme, tous les jours.
Avec sa mère,
c'est elle qui mène la maison.
-Quel âge avez-vous ?
-15 ans et demi.
-Savez-vous ce que signifie 15 ans
et 3 mois pour une jeune fille ?
-C'est l'âge de se marier.
-Vous y avez pensé ?
-Pas beaucoup, pas encore.
-Vous vous trouvez trop jeune ?
-Oui.
-A quel âge
voudrez-vous vous marier ?
-17-18 ans.
-Le mariage,
c'est quoi pour vous ?
-C'est lorsque...
Un homme et une femme
sont unis pour toutes leurs vies.
Alors,
on ne doit pas se quitter,
..on doit rester ensemble.
Et puis,
c'est fait pour faire une famille.
-Qu'est-ce qu'un homme,
pour vous ?
-Pour moi, un homme..
..c'est quelqu'un qui est
supérieur à la femme.
Il est destiné aux travaux
des champs, ou plus durs travaux.
Et un mari, quand il a
des enfants, il s'en occupe.
Il est un peu responsable
de ses enfants, quand même.
-Croyez-vous qu'un mari
doit faire la vaisselle ?
-Non, je ne pense pas.
-Et laver le linge des enfants ?
-Ce rôle est plutôt
attribuer à la femme.
-Vous ne pensez pas qu'on
pourrait partager les rôles ?
-Les rôles pourraient
se partager, mais un homme..
..n'est pas destiné pour faire
la lessive et la vaisselle.
-Nicole, 16 ans,
..travaille dans une
petite usine de Grenoble.
Nicole et Henri sont fiancés
depuis décembre.
Ils se marieront quand Henri
aura fait son service militaire.
Les problèmes sont simples,
..l'argent, le logement.
Dans la vie,
..il y a des difficultés.
On est là pour les résoudre.
Par rapport à Caroline,
à Odile, à Marie-France,
..Nicole a beaucoup plus
qu'un an de plus.
-Comment vous allez..
..distribuer les rôles,
que ferez vous, que fera lui ?
-Ce qu'il fera lui...
Si on travail tous les deux,
en rentrant du travail,
..on se partagera s'il y a du
ménage à faire, on se partagera.
Lui fera la vaisselle, moi je ferai
la chambre, ou l'inverse.
-Quand vous serez mariée,
continuerez-vous à travailler ?
-Oui, parce que tant
qu'on aura pas d'enfant,
..je continuerai, pour
aider le ménage, parce qu'on..
..sera bien obligé.
Et pour avoir plus d'affaires
plus vite, quoi.
-Et quand vous aurez des enfants,
vous cesserez de travailler ?
-Je ne sais pas. Ca dépend
combien je gagnerai par moi.
Si ça ne me reviens
pas plus cher...
Je n'aimerais pas faire garder
mes enfants. Les mettre au monde..
..sans les élever,
ce n'est pas bien.
-Vous élèverez les filles
comme les garçons ?
-Oui. Oui.
Vous voulez dire sans préférence
pour l'un ou l'autre ?
-Non, ferez-vous faire des études
aux garçons, pas aux filles ?
-Oui, tous pareils.
Si on peut se permettre..
..de payer des études au garçon
comme à la fille, bien sûr.
-Mais si vous ne pouviez pas
vous le permettre,
..comment vous choisiriez ?
-Je ne sais pas.
On ferait peut-être
comme mes parents ont fait.
Par exemple, faire étudier
le garçon en premier,
..et que le garçon travaille,
et que la fille..
..fasse ses études,
et travaille après.
-Chacun son tour.
-Oui.
-Pensez-vous qu'une femme
doit avoir des idées politiques,
..et s'occuper de politique ?
-Oui.
Parce qu'une femme a beaucoup
à dire sur certaines choses.
Elle voit peut-être mieux
le problème qu'un garçon.
-Les problèmes politiques
ou syndicaux ?
-Syndicaux ou politiques.
-Pourquoi une femme voit
mieux les choses qu'un garçon ?
-Elle a peut-être l'esprit
plus large.
Une femme s'occupe bien plus
de choses qu'un homme.
Par exemple, dans le ménage,
même si l'homme aide,
..c'est différent.
Les femmes ont certaines choses,
..leurs revendications..
..à démontrer,
..à voir.
Et les hommes, autre chose.
Pas tout à fait
dans la même ligne.
-Exemple...
-D'abord, pour le travail.
Un homme pourra peut-être faire..
..9 heures par jour,
7 pour la femme,
..car elle a son ménage
à s'occuper.